well i'm now joined by labour's national
campaign coordinator shabana mahmoud
thanks for your time on sky news this
morning now looking at the by-election
um yesterday in old bexley and sid cup
conservatives then managed to they won
by more than 50 percent of the election
and this is despite the allegations of
sleaze and the crisis that we're seeing
at the channel crossing there and they
still manage to get 50 off the votes
this is not boding very well for you
guys is it
oh look old bexley and zip sibcop is a a
tory stronghold of long standing um and
they had a majority of 19 000 in this
seat uh which was slashed last night to
just over four thousand um and i think
that what what i saw when i was out
there campaigning myself is that the
incompetence of the prime minister and
the litany of broken promises are
catching up with him
and and i think we've seen that
reflected uh in the result by uh by any
measure and by any by-election standards
a 10.3 swing uh 10.3 swing towards us um
is an extremely good result for the
labour party uh because we know that uh
if that result was uh replicated uh on a
uniform swing across the country a
general election that would put us
within touching distance of a majority
labour government so i think the prime
minister should be worried because tory
campaigners in that seat will know that
a true blue tory heartland like old
bexley and sidcop was returning a lot of
dissatisfaction with the prime minister
in his government and people are very uh
frustrated they are fed up they're fed
up with the sleaze they're fed up with
the broken promises and i think many
tory voters registered that yesterday
some of them stayed at home and many of
them made the switch over to the to the
labour party and uh for that reason it's
a very good result for us
but are they though because as i said
they've got 50 percent of the votes also
your leader zakir dharma is really
struggling to push through to people he
has made some gains of course when it
comes to the polling um this week but
overall he's just not pushing through is
he boris johnson still maintains his
position
i think a 10.3 percent swing uh in as i
say a tory
heartland i mean this is as true blue as
it gets it's not a seat that we uh even
uh took in 1997 when uh we had a
landslide uh labor uh majority uh in
that general election so this is true
blue tory heartlands and the 10.3 swing
to the labour party in this kind of
territory a seat that voted uh for leave
in the brexit referendum uh you know i
think that that uh is an extremely good
result and i i was out on the doorstep
on number of occasions myself uh
campaigning uh in old bexlin syd cup and
uh you know we we were seeing tory
voters uh dissatisfied with the prime
minister fed up with the government and
wanting to take a second look at the
labour party something that they had not
ever done before many of those made the
switch over to us and we're very
grateful for their support uh in in in
the by-election and many others uh were
willing to give uh kierstarma and the
labour party a fresh look because they
are frustrated with the government and i
think that's been reflected in the huge
thing that we've seen towards the labour
party in that result
now sharon graham is a new general
secretary of unites your party's biggest
financial backer has warned that they
will cut funding direct it elsewhere
this must be very worrying for your
party
well look trade unions pay affiliation
fees uh to the labour party and that's
not change as far as united are
concerned but of course at what they do
with the rest of their money that they
um collect from their members for
political campaigning it's always been
the case that some of that is directed
towards the labour party and some of it
goes into other local campaigns nothing
that sharon graham the new general
secretary of unite said uh recently is
is a change on what we've always
expected and what is standard practice
amongst trade unions and certainly what
she said uh her union was intending to
do upon her election so i'm afraid
there's nothing really to see here uh
trade unions always fund different types
of campaigning across the country and we
are not concerned about the support that
we're receiving from our partners in the
trade union movement
so how much money are you expecting then
i'm not going to get into the details of
budgets and money here and that's not
appropriate we receive affiliation fees
from the trade union officially
we receive affiliation fees from the uh
trade unions that are officially
affiliated to the labour party uh and
that's always uh recorded and published
it's a very transparent process it's the
cleanest money uh in politics and uh you
will see that when that comes in but
we're also expecting as we always get
from our friends across the trade union
movement it's not just one trade union
there's a number of trade unions that
support the labour party and i'm sure
they will continue to do so ahead of the
general election
very quickly christmas parties will you
be holding any at all
my staff and i uh a small team in my
constituency office in birmingham we
normally have a small get-together and
we're intending to continue with that
we'll obviously follow all the guidance
that's available at the time and we will
take our precautions with our squaring
and so on as well but um i i we all want
to see uh christmas um go ahead as um
and people to enjoy themselves we want
to see the government do everything in
their power to make sure that everybody
can have a good christmas and that means
getting this new variant in particular
under control we have called for the
government to introduce or reintroduce
pre-travel testing
for people coming into the uk we think
that that is one of the strongest
measures that the government can take to
make sure that the new variant does not
spread and that christmas is not
affected
shabana mahmood labour party national
campaign manager thank you very much
indeed for your time thank you